this is why do I need to know python I'm
a pandas user we're at Pi data London it
is June 18 2022 actually no that's not
correct we're actually at Pi data New
York City
and it is Wednesday November 9th
2022 and the reason that I got the date
here wrong is because
this was actually a talk that I had
originally prepared for pi data London
and pro tip do not change the password
on the only laptop that has a copy
representation 30 minutes before your
presentation is pro tip number two great
password choices P at sign dollar sign
dollar sign w0rd now let's see if I can
actually give this presentation and
it'll be effective and the presentation
here is about well you're a pandas user
why do you need to know anything about
python sure python or rather pandas is
written in Python but how much do I
really need to know Tuple versus list
come on I'll just try one and if it
doesn't work I'll try the other and so
to set the tone for you let's take a
look let's say that you're a pandas user
and the majority of the work that you do
is work like this you have some time
series data Maybe in a multi-index dates
and entities and there's some signal in
some data frame that you're working with
and your data looks something like let's
it's going
oops let's actually get this going a
little bit better than that
and then we'll get started
and so yeah something that kind of looks
like this and you have some data frame
and the data frame is basically some
kind of Time series data entities and
signals and most of the work that you're
doing is grouping by this entity maybe
doing a transform maybe you saw this
Lambda as part of some kind of chaining
syntax but for the most part you just
memorize the syntax what do you really
need to know python for if you're a
pandas user
I want to try and answer this question
for you by answering this in terms of
four separate questions and the very
first question that I want to tackle for
you is why do the basics of python even
matter if you're just a pandas user
who's doing Group by operations rolling
operations manipulations on columns in a
data frame well let's take a look
let's say you're a pandas user and
you're working with Excel data and you
know that there is no guarantee that in
that Excel data the actual table you
want to read is in the top left corner
so when you read this in using
pandas.read Excel how hard can it be it
turns out you get some garbage like this
because a person who created the Excel
file actually put the data on the second
row and there's some there's actually
two data sets in here you can see
there's a first data set and the second
data set and what are you going to do
you're going to go into this data frame
and drop the nands and try and extract
the data no what you're going to do is
you're going to use Pi Excel and use Pi
Excel to actually manipulate this data
to actually pull out what you need
because good luck telling the original
author of this data please fix your data
set it's really screwing up my process
and when you do that you'll notice for
example
Pi Excel does not implement the context
manager protocol when you open the file
so you have to learn about
contextlive.closing because if you write
some script and that script is analyzing
that file and the script does not close
the file you will find that you cannot
rename it you can't move it into the
trash can you have to reboot your
computer just to change the name of the
file so maybe it's worth learning just a
little bit about python maybe it's worth
learning about things like context of
that closing but when you take a look at
the file you might say Okay I want to go
into that file and figure out where the
data is and I may actually know where
the data is maybe it's consistently in
some place so I want to represent the
view area for the data is and you could
represent this as a tuple or a list of
lists but maybe a little bit more
readable way to represent this would be
as a collections.name tuple where you
can say this is the minimum and maximum
row minimum maximum column where I
expect my data to be maybe it's worth
learning about collections.name Tuple
because it'll give you a little bit of
guidance for how you can extract the
data you can go to Open PI Excel and say
give me just the cells in this
particular location and if the data set
changes maybe you can toggle these or
maybe you can even write some code that
infers where the data is supposed to be
by just scanning through the Excel
spreadsheet whatever the case may be it
might actually be valuable to learn a
little bit of python in order to make
this very routine task a bit easier now
once you've started on this path you
might say okay I've got my name Tuple
I've got my Open PI Excel I want to work
with this data but what's the guarantee
that the data actually has The Columns
of that order because they might not
move it around on the spreadsheet but
they might change the order of the
columns or even add in extra columns how
do we know that it's name group and
value well maybe you might be
advantageous for you to learn a little
bit about python syntax maybe what that
assert is because you could add a very
simple line setting assert that the data
looks the way that it's supposed to look
and warm me if it doesn't so if maybe
they swap the columns your analyzes
don't just break for no good reason
well if you're gonna do that you might
wonder should this be an assert or not
and it might be worth learning a little
bit about how the python internals work
to understand for example that asserts
are used for programmatic documentation
they are not for checking business logic
they're for documenting so that somebody
knows as of this line of code we know
that the cells look a certain way we
know that our data has been written
correctly and it may require that we
understand things like there's a debug
variable with two underscores before and
after that is automatically defined by
your python interpreter that is by
default set to true there's a dash
capital O flag that sets that to false
Python's constant folding allows it to
align blocks of code which it knows will
never run and it allows it to align
assert statements and so those assert
statements are not necessarily run if
you run python with a dash o flag which
means you could put very expensive data
checks behind an if debug flag or in an
assert and when you're running in your
debug mode you can run those checks but
when you deploy this to production you
don't have to run the checks because
maybe you're a little bit a little bit
more convinced the data set looks right
and in fact it might be worth learning
about things like the disk module so you
can see this yourself here you can see
the assert when I actually look at the
code when I run this with python-0 it
vanishes which means we now have a way
in Python without learning that much
about python to add very expensive
checks to our code to make sure that our
data is correct
and all it took was learning about
the debug flag and the assert might be
worth learning about that now
when you are doing your analysis you
might say okay I have my data set I load
it in I defined what the area is I
checked a couple of things I'm going to
create a data frame from it and it's
very likely that that's what you're
going to do with this data you're going
to create a data frame you might use
something like two numeric and at this
point
no big deal use all you know about
pandas read in that data frame do your
group by everything is fine
except what if you have more than one
data file what if you have a bunch of
data files and they're in some directory
and it's not just a one data file who's
hard-coded path you know but any of the
data files that happen to be in the
directory in this case this data
directory which happens to have a bunch
of data files for the US for EU for
pricing for demand information and so
forth and so on and it even has one data
file this manifests that maybe I don't
want to read in and it might be worth
learning just a little bit about python
like passive.path because it gives us
the ability to very easily manipulate
paths on disk for example iterating
through the paths and finding everything
that has a CSV suffix and only
processing the CSV files and ignoring
any of those metadata files that aren't
necessarily relevant for the analytical
use case itself in fact it might even be
worth learning about things like the
python set because you could think you
could put all of the files you want to
read into a python set and then you can
Mark any files that you know should not
be read like a bad file that contains
corrupted data that we'll fix that later
but I just don't to read it from my
analysis you can put that instead and do
set subtraction and only process the
files that you want and if somebody says
oh we fixed that file no big deal you
could make this an empty set and
everything's good or if there's other
files you want to skip you could do that
and you can do a very readable readable
way now once you do that it might be
worth learning about things like
comprehension syntax because we've
expressed the finding of all the files
that we have on disk and the removal of
the bad files in literally two lines of
code to Define these and one set
subtraction and here you can see go to
my directory find every file that's a
CSV ignore this one file for now and
these are the files I'm going to process
and putting that all together you might
then go through the files read them in
and there we go we have our analysis
with each of the files Additionally you
can notice that there's an in-band
encoding in use here the file names
themselves include information about
what they contain it's in the name EU
dot pricing maybe it's worth learning a
little bit about the string operation so
you can do something with that string
like split it into two different strings
one of which tells you this is the
region that the file contains data for
and this is the region or this is the
metric that it has and in fact you might
say it might be a little bit worth my
time to learn about things like regular
Expressions because I can do that just a
little bit safer I can write a simple
regular expression that says every file
name that I want to process ends with
the region and the column that I'm going
to create with the CSV file and thus I
can go through all of my files and only
match the files that have this pattern
to read them in I can of course remove
any bad files that I know are
problematic and with just a little bit
of python I can do things that would
otherwise be extraordinarily manual and
extraordinarily difficult
well once you start doing that you might
say Okay I want to read in these files
and I want to do something with them
well I know that the data types that I'm
given by pandas and by numpy do not
nicely grow in place they are genuinely
or generally dynamically shaped but
fixed size which means if I have to read
a bunch of data I should probably first
read it into a list and at the very tail
and do a concatenation and so here it
might be worth doing something like
reading in the data files into some kind
of python dictionary using this
dictionary comprehension syntax doing
some kind of concatenation on all the
files based off what the regions are in
order to create my final product which
is all of the different data files that
I have here are the actual data file
names and all of the data frames that
were created from these data files I was
able to do this in only a couple of
lines of code it might just be worth
your time to learn a little bit of
python even if you happen to be a pandas
user let's take a look at our next
question and this next question is why
does looping even matter in my life I'm
a panda's user what do I need to know
about looping because after all I
learned everything I need to know about
looping what I learned about numpy I
learned about broadcasting and
vectorized operations I learned that
when you take two numpy and dras there
are rules that dictate how those are
interrelated how those things may
support a particular operation for
example here you can see I'm doing an
element-wise multiplication of these two
structures and it's going to broadcast
one to the other and you might even have
taken the time to learn that the
broadcasting works by first right
aligning the coordinates or right
aligning the sizes of these and then
matching them up either exactly or
looking for a one and so here this is
going to repeat this structure three
times on that axis there and you say
that's all I need to know about looping
in fact I'm not even to post the loop if
I'm using pandas or numpy let the
restrict a computation domain handle
that I want to do everything in those
vectorized operations myself you
probably along the way have said the
word vectorized 16 times already
why do we need to know about looping
where does this come up even for a
pandas user well it turns out that maybe
we have some Panda series and in that
Panda series we want to do operations
like resample this data and it may not
be the case that we want to resample
this in some consistent fashion maybe
one user wants to resample in one way
another wants to resamp it another way
maybe for our analysis we want to do
some kind of rolling and one person
wants to smooth the data by seven days
somebody else wants to smooth the day by
three days there could be a lot of
hidden modalities here but largely you
can see much of the looping is handled
by pandas itself as long as the looping
we're talking about is the computational
looping here we can see some examples of
manipulating this Panda series and
Performing operations like looking up
something after resampling the structure
on the periods and then finding the mean
and we can even see a little bit of
piping syntax here but it's still not
clear to me
he said the looping that I do
computationally would be done in pandas
what else is there other than
computational looping well it turns out
that when we're using something like a
pandas data frame appendix series or an
Umpire we are acknowledging that python
has two separate domains the domain
where you do your computations you do
these via these kind of operations these
broadcasted operations and the domain
where you describe the problem you're
trying to solve what I like to call
program structuring that's where python
lives and that's where knowing a little
bit more about python looping might help
you even if you're a panda's user
because it turns out that when you have
your data frame you might want to do
some analysis on it you want to do some
scenario analysis for example you have
some low risk situation and some high
risk situation and these correspond to
multipliers on the columns that you have
in the lower situation you're going to
multiply the a column and the B column
by these values in a higher situation
you do this maybe this is some kind of
perturbative risk analysis well whatever
the case may be you definitely know
everything there is to know about index
alignment but you might not realize that
we can express the scenario analysis
very nicely just using simple mechanisms
of python for example here I am defining
the scenarios that I'm going to apply
I'm going to apply them to my data set
and I have a nice simple little
comprehension syntax that says for each
one of my scenarios apply them to my
data set using the index alignment and
give me the results and you can see this
is my lowest kind of high-risk analysis
how would you do this without that
looping syntax you'd have a bunch of cut
and paste code but you know I'm a pandas
user why do I why do I care well it
turns out that the scenario analysis
tends to be a lot more complicated than
just that it may be the case that I want
to dictate my scenarios print out the
results but the scenarios aren't just
this one this one this one in a row
there may be some complex
interrelationship between them for
example I have multiple different
scenarios that I want to compare against
each other I have regimes and
adjustments I'm in a low risk or a high
risk regime I'm doing a low overhead or
a high overhead adjustment and I want to
look at the Cartesian product low risk
low overhead low risk High overhead high
risk low overhead high risk High
overhead and in this case do I really
want to be cutting and pasting two times
two four times no because I could use
itter tools.product in order to set up
the structure of the analysis I'm trying
to do and compute all of these different
scenarios at once in one simple python
Loop it might just be worth your time to
learn about the inner tools module
because it allows you to express how you
want to structure your analysis in terms
of what are you going to actually be
analyzing even though the underlying
copy mutational work will still be
handled by numpy or by pandas
well it turns out that this may be an
even more effective approach than you
think because this allows you to
separately specify what the analysis is
going to look like you can see
independently these are the four
scenarios I'm going to do and if I put
this into a python set I could even
subtract out scenarios that nobody cares
about maybe they want to see the
Cartesian products just minus this one
case that we don't think is actually
going to happen and I can express all of
these in a fluent fashion by just
learning a tiny bit about python
in fact
when I do this I may discover that I
have a very complex set of these
scenarios that I want to analyze and I
want to be able to fluently Express
don't just do this one scenario do all
these scenarios and give it make it
possible for me to just randomly add
extra scenarios I'll make my business
users happy if they say oh and this one
more thing and it's just one line of
code that makes use of all of these
looping mechanisms that are provided by
the standard Library by the inner tools
module but it goes a little bit further
than that because it may be the case
that for my scenario analysis and here
you can see the result of my previous
computation for my scenario analysis I
may want to do something even more
complicated for example
I may have some scenarios and for those
scenarios I may even have
let's go past this one
I might even have some scenarios and
those scenarios are ordered in some
linear fashion like a happens and then B
happens and C happens and D happens and
E happens and I want to compare from A
to B what happened from B to C what
happened from C to D what happened from
D to e what happened and I could do that
using the other two's module recently in
the python standard library in the inner
tools module we added pairwise which
gives us the ability to look at pairs of
elements here you can see I could do an
analysis of my data let's get this one
going where I can compare a against b b
against c c again d d against e
preserving that linear ordering looking
at those in overlapping pairs very
similar to a pandas rolling with a size
of two now
I know in the audience we have some
people who are looking at this slide and
saying pairwise what on Earth is going
on
for those of you here's analyze NYS is
my generalization of pairwise looking at
Windows of any arbitrary size by
building from the building blocks in the
inner tools module something even more
powerful than what it gives me itself
and so here you can see my favorite
little iteration Helper and wise with
the idea of NYS I can do the exact same
thing that pairwise has but if I wanted
to look at scenarios with some other
window size like for example the
previous scenario the current scenario
and the next scenario I could do that as
well and here we can see just a little
bit of looping and a little bit of pure
python gets me very very far here I'm
comparing a against B again c b again C
against d c against D against e and so
forth and so on and in fact if I just
take that one little idea and take it
further I might write other iteration
helpers I might write iteration helpers
like ny's longest or first and last
which then allow me to fluently Express
exactly what I want to do in my analysis
in this analysis I want to look at the
first scenario all by itself then I want
to look what happens between the first
and the second scenario the second and
the third the third and the fourth and
then I want the last scenario all by
itself in in isolation and it's just the
combination of these tools from the
inner tools module that allows me to set
up a very fluent Loop here which says
look through the previous and the
current scenario identify which is the
very first in the order which is the
very last in the order if you're in the
first one do something here maybe it's
part of your analysis you may or may not
use some sort of factor where you may
perform the analysis slightly
differently for everything else do this
and if for the last scenario do this
here it might just be worth your time to
learn a little bit more about looping
learn about things like the editor tools
module even if you happen to be a pandas
user
well if we're if we're talking about
looping we better talk about things like
generators because you saw in the
previous example a generator expression
that's the thing with the squigglies
that are kind of like that the round
thing around the thing that has the four
in the internet your panties here who
cares but
when we talk about things like
generators you might say well that's
good if I have iterators or iterables
but I don't have iterators or iterables
it's a very kind of mechanical thing who
cares about generators I'm a panda's
user well it turns out that generators
are probably the most useful feature in
all of python
semicolon that you also aren't using
today because
generators aren't just some mechanical
thing that makes the python programmers
very happy to talk about iterables and
iterators generators are your mechanism
by which you can express non-closed form
operations without specifying the end
modality that sounds like a lot of
verbiage but I'll tell you what that
means let's say we have some analysis
and that analysis is done in numpy well
we know that performing operations
inside numpy is definitely a better idea
than performing those operations in some
Loop in the pure python level in fact
simple performance analysis shows us
that's the case here we have a DOT
product implemented in pure python and a
DOT products implemented in numpy and we
can see that there is an order of
magnitude difference between the two of
them and so when I tell you about things
like generators you might say well hold
on a second it sounds a lot like you
want me to loop at the pure python level
which is going to be a terrible
performance hit but it turns out that
when we're talking about generators
we're generally talking about particular
regime a regime that you may not even
recognize in your code until I show it
to you here's how it works
in computation or at least in Python we
have two ways to represent a computation
a computation perhaps that doesn't have
a closed form that can't be done in a
single shot we have ego representations
of computation that's what a function is
it does a bunch of work before you ask
it completes the entire computation and
gives you the results
if it's the case that you have some
computation that you can break into
parts and the incremental part of that
computation is way faster than waiting
to ask somebody should I keep going then
you do not want to use generators you
want to use numpy you want to use pandas
because numpy and pandas are
fundamentally eager computational tools
what might this look like well in the
previous example you can see the
incremental computation was a multiply
how fast is a multiply very very fast to
ask a multiply do I keep going or not
we'll require going into the python
level which will take on the order of
microseconds I can do a multiply and
much much less time than a microsecond
and so when we look at examples where we
are doing operations on computational
data it is often the case that we see
some perplexing results like what we can
see here here I have a numpyendra
containing values drawn from a normal
distribution and in that numpy India
right I Am timing the amount of time it
takes to find all of the positive values
and square them and I'm doing that with
two syntaxes in the latter syntax I'm
indexing into that structure and
squaring all the values that are greater
than zero in the former syntax I am
squaring every value and then
multiplying times a mask that is only
one if the value is greater than zero
and is zero otherwise this line of code
does more work than the second line of
code and yet it's faster it's over two
times faster if it's the case at the
incremental computation is so blazingly
fast then it's oftentimes Worth to do
extra work and just throw it away
because the time to ask or the time to
mask is going to be bigger than the time
to do a bunch of computations you throw
away this is the regime that you're used
to but it is not the only regime in
which our computations sit because in
the other regime we're talking about
lazy computations and lazy computations
or any computation where the time to do
an incremental slip is significantly
slower than the time to make a decision
so if it takes one second to compute and
it takes me one microsecond to ask you
want me to keep going I better ask each
time because otherwise I could waste a
lot of computational resources in fact
anytime I have a simulation a solver a
Optimizer and in that Optimizer I have
some ending modality simulate for how
many steps simulate until what condition
is met if the underlying simulation step
itself is slow and by that I mean more
than maybe a microsecond of time it is
probably the case that you want to write
this as a generator let me show you an
example here I have a simulate and it
runs forever and it
operates on some fairly slow step
performed on some data frame now when I
think about how I write this when I
think about how I formulate this
computation I might say well my users
want to be able to simulate for 100
steps 200 steps 300 steps I'll add a
modality I'll add a num steps parameter
and that'll be fine until some user says
well I can't tell a priori how many
steps or the best number of steps to run
for my machine learning training how
many steps do I train for I can't tell
unless I look at the data so actually
can you give me a threshold parameter
because I want to run this until I see
that threshold parameter and then I want
to stop because otherwise I might be
doing extra work and some other user
comes to and says you know what I don't
care about the exact values I only have
a somewhat loose time budget of maybe
one second to train this for before I
have to deploy it so I don't know the
number of steps I don't know the
threshold but I know the amount of clock
time that I want to spend in the
simulator and when you want to satisfy
all of those users this is the nonsense
that you're going to write for them
three different modalities three
different parameters to make everybody
happy but you will never be able to make
everybody happy because the moment you
show them that you're willing to
accommodate such a ridiculous request
they're going to come to and they're
going to say well actually what I want
to do is I want to train my machine
learning algorithm until the relative
Improvement between every two steps
falls under some threshold or I want to
change that threshold from an absolute
threshold to a relative threshold or I
want to support both modes and you'll
see that this grows and grows and grows
without bound your misery will grow
without bound if you believe that any
closed non-closed form operation which
may have different ending modalities
like a simulator a solver a machine
learning trainer whatever the case may
be if you're trying to accommodate all
of those
but if you use a generator what you're
doing is you're representing that
computation as an unbounded sequence of
steps and you're externalizing the
control of that computation you are not
preferring any modality over any other
modality you're just running this
forever and externally from the way in
which this computation is modeled your
users decide will actually want to run
for end steps well actually I want to
run until some threshold is is met well
actually I want to run for some total
time and in fact you can write simpler
code
that has less of a maintenance burden
for you and is more flexible for your
end users you can satisfy all of these
modalities by externalizing the
condition under which the simulation
stops well that's all a generator is a
generator is the idea that a computation
has multiple steps but I won't tell you
ahead of time how many steps I want to
run I will just structure this
computation and I'll let you externally
decide via the inner tools module that's
come up twice already hasn't
but it turns out that this is a mistake
that you see throughout libraries that
are computational in nature and you
might say well no people couldn't
couldn't be missing out on such a big
win
scipy.optimize.newton Newton's method
runs for a number of steps to find the
zeros of a polynomial let's look at the
help text for it well scipy
optimized.newton takes a max number of
iterations or a relative tolerance or an
absolute tolerance those all look like
modalities that are trying to decide
when do you stop optimizing and you
might say well hold on a second it's PSI
Pi that's what means it's probably
written in C nope
scipyoptimize.newton is just a big old
python for Loop they should have written
this as a generator because if they
written as a generator they wouldn't
need those arguments at all they would
have just run the optimizer forever and
then had somebody externally decide I
slice it down to the steps that I want
to run because all the generator is
doing is exposing the computational
steps to The Interpreter to allow you to
decide where they keep going or not and
this works if it's the case that the
incremental computation is slower than
the time that it takes to make a
decision which is likely to be the case
for an Optimizer maybe maybe not but
you're already in the python levels
you're already paying the cost for it
anyway
now
from all of this you might see it might
just be worth my time to learn about
things like generators in fact tools
like generators are a fantastic way to
simplify your apis while making them
broadly more powerful and this is one of
my favorite examples that I like to
share with people this is called the
genetic algorithms example here you can
see I am modeling a genetic algorithm
where the incremental steps are
considered to be slow enough because
it's doing a lot of numpy manipulation
and I'm doing it by modeling the actual
genetic algorithm step as an infinite
sequence of steps so that somebody
externally can say run this until I hit
a Target Fitness or run this for a fixed
number of steps or run until the fitness
is no longer increasing and what I like
about this example is hidden within this
example in order to handle things like
the single point crossover you may even
use tricks like the masking trick
because if the incremental computation
is fast enough it may be worth just
doing extra computations and throwing
them away but if the overall computation
is slow enough then you might want to
model this generator in fact anything
that you have where you have a
multi-step computation and the
computational step takes more than maybe
about a microsecond probably you want to
model its generator to eliminate all of
those modalities that make your code a
lot harder for you to use and preclude
certain ways of stopping that
computation
now
here you can see my my work my play
I want to answer the last question for
you and in this last question I want to
answer for you why does object
orientation even matter
well I guess Panda's data frame is an
object it's got methods on it and the
numpy and dra is an object and it
sometimes has methods and sometimes
doesn't have methods like why did they
put mean on the ND array but not median
why is that like a function that you
have to import why is it that in pandas
you have mean and standard deviation
skew and kurtosis as methods but in
numpy you have to import actually in
numpy you have to import it from scipy
well it turns out that object
orientation is something that we can get
very deep in the Weeds about but
fundamentally the core idea of object
orientation is how do we find better
ways to structure the code in our
program and you might look at this and
say why do I care I'm a pandas user
because you know what I'm more than
happy to write some pandas code where
I'm basically cutting and pasting things
I have two data frames I'm going to
operate on and I'm going to do some
operational data frames maybe clip them
within some particular region from
negative 0.25 to 0.25 and I'm going to
subset those data frames and I'm going
to do some grouping and you know what
yeah it's a little bit of cut and paste
but come on what more do I need in fact
if it's the case that I see somebody's
looking at this gun they're like yeah I
just did that this morning right if it's
the case that I see all of this
duplication in my code
does it really end because we want to
subset it in different ways you can see
this is kind of geometric growth of the
cutting and pasting here I'm first
clicking the data frames and then I'm
subsetting them on the on the greater
than zero and the lower than zero and
then performing all the different group
buys on each one of these sets and every
time I add another aspect to this I'm
just duplicating the amount of cut and
paste I have to have and almost
certainly someone here in the audience
has a data frame where or it has a
Jupiter notebook where there is df1 df2
df3 underscore Temp df4 and it's
basically the same code being cutting
paste all over the place and where that
really Burns you is what if I decide to
change the column that I'm going to do
the grouping on I got to change it in
four places and it's very easy we forget
to change that in four places a little
bit of data structuring might help
well do I really need data structuring
because I could write these as methods
right and I could kind of simplify the
logic I could create a single source of
Truth for how to perform this operation
and then I guess I could do something
like take the grouping and write that as
a method I could I could just change it
in one place so I don't know I still
don't see the case for object
orientation I feel like this is just a
case where I just need functions and
I'm a panda user but I'm at least
willing to learn functions because those
are the things that get my work done
well it turns out that simple object
orientation is a very effective way for
us to simplify the structure of our code
to gain real benefits because if we take
this function idea a little bit further
we'll see that we start growing
modalities and starts getting very
clumsy we start making certain
assumptions of how the data frame looks
and we have all these functions floating
around that have all sorts of
assumptions about how many columns there
are what the columns look like and I
don't know that I'm really gaining
anything because here even though I have
a function I still have these two
modalities whether I'm going to uh do
the greater than zero or the less than
zero I don't know that I'm really
gaining anything or I'm reducing that
much cut and paste well
what I might do is I might make use of
the absolute bare minimum of object
orientation in Python I might use a
boilerplate elimination tool like a
collections.name tuple or a data
class.data class I might create some
structure that allows me to give it a
data frame and to perform operations to
store within it the data frame subject
to some sort of data cleaning I may give
it some additional options like hey
given the data frame that you have give
me the subsetted version I may say
here's another operation given the data
frame give me the grouped version and I
can represent the overall analyzes as
some entity in my program where
previously this overall analysis was
represented the program but in the form
of multiple disconnected lines that were
cut and paste all over the place I can
group things and structure things a
little bit better and when I do that I
might say
you know what this might have some
benefits here is a block of code that I
wrote a while back and it was to
demonstrate something that I thought was
very interesting which is to say that
when you look at where tuples are
allocated in a python process and we
look where numpy and d-rays are not
going to python process numpy and dras
are always allocated at lower memory
addresses than tupas and I was really
curious why might it be the case so I
did I went out and I collected some data
and I collected all the locations of all
the allocations over a sample program
and I said okay I want to compare all
the different ways that these things are
allocated to try and understand
what's going on here I want to try and
find the pattern programmatically and as
I started cutting and pasting my way
through all of this code reading cutting
and pasting the read CSV code cutting
and pasting all of the manipulation code
I said I need some data structuring
because I'm losing my mind cutting and
pasting all over the place and I reached
for the most simplistic structure that I
could have a name Tuple with a couple of
methods I wrote a class that allows me
to instantiate some analysis from a CSV
file by reading in that CSV file I wrote
something that allows me to instantiate
this analysis from some raw data frame
and it goes in that data frame and it
does some data parsing it does all of my
little operations to extract The Columns
that I want to clean up the data to
parse the data to split this into
multi-index columns which I wish we had
time to talk about that's another talk
called why don't you know why do I need
to learn how to use pandas I'm a pandas
user but we'll set that off for later
here you can see I even thought you know
what for this analysis I want to see
where these different these different
entities are are located so I want to be
able to compare them and I said to
myself I want to use a slightly more
nuanced approach to object orientation I
want to for example have these methods
be named methods not the underscore
methods because for example I might not
want somebody to mistakenly distinguish
this thing or mistakenly be unable to
distinguish this thing from an actual
pandas data frame so I want this to
really just be an analysis density an
energy that represents the work that I'm
doing that programmatically structures
how I'm performing that analysis and
that allows me to write this code this
is some of the my favorite code that I
wrote over the last year because you can
read it and understand exactly what it's
doing load in my data for the tuples
load in my data for ND arrays
the Tuple allocation covers a large
range tell me what the addresses of the
tuples are tell me how many unique
addresses there are tell me what the
mean and the standard deviation of where
the Tuple locations are so we can see
where these are located we can even
graph them
and here this is the output
okay
given that do the same thing for the
ndra repeat the exact same analysis and
tell me what's the max location where
the ndra was allocated the Min location
the mean and the standard deviation and
the unique and you can see I have that
analysis there I've cut and pasted into
this file give me the range of addresses
comparatively give me how far apart they
are the Min and the max the Max and the
Min you can see this kind of geometric
expansion where if I have two
characteristics and two characteristics
I'm going to have four things that can
go ahead and paste well here I just have
the two lines answering those questions
directly
see if I can discover where the
discontinuity is between the Tuple
allocations because when you do this you
actually see the tuples under 59
elements are allocated in one place and
over 60 elements are out in another
place and you can programmatically show
that discontinuity by just taking the
structure
and Computing these groups by the mean
finding where those groups are looking
at the index Min of those two and then
doing a little bit of index line
operations here and we can see that
tuples of PSI 59 are allocated here two
plus a size 60 are allocated here you
can visually see that programmatically
then
tuples of size 60 a assert that they are
always before the ndra memory
irrespective allocation order and assert
the other one for tuples of size 60
assert that maybe they are before maybe
they are after and you can see the
majority of this code is not the cut and
paste to do the analysis the majority of
this code is telling the story of what
I'm trying to accomplish which largely
you can see here is somewhat mechanical
but I think it's still broadly
applicable to the kinds of problems you
want to solve because ultimately when we
have some computational structure when
we have a data frame we want to be able
to do operations on we want to be able
to do operations like assign new new
columns and we want to be able to do
that in such a way where if the data
changes that column is updated and we
might try to do this as a function but
that doesn't quite work out for us we
might try doing this as some kind of
analysis object and we get a little bit
of a benefit there we might even we
might even be tempted to do this using
something like the registered data frame
accessors to extend a pandas data frame
to have extra methods like dot computed
where you can always recompute values
dynamically but let's be realistic
you're a panda's user you don't care
about object orientation you don't care
about generators you don't care about
Loop and you don't care about python
Basics but here's something you might
care about
um this is a little bit of python just a
couple of little mechanics
that allows you to Alias columns so you
can give a column two names so you can
give it a really pretty name so it shows
up nicely on your matpot lip graphs and
get a really easy name so you can use
that dotted access and maybe
if you happen to be a data scientist
maybe you might be motivated by the
convenience of the things that you can
do and the capability to do things that
you didn't think possible without
cutting and pasting code without writing
code that nobody can make heads or tails
of later writing code that somebody can
understand and amend that they can
extend and grow maybe you might do that
and if that happens to be you well I'd
encourage you to follow me on Twitter or
LinkedIn my name is James Powell
but in all truths
why do you need to know about python
you're a panda's user thank you so much
[Applause]
we have a couple of minutes
yes so thank you very much for the
presentation so coming back to the
example that you made with sci-fi.com
um sometimes it's hard to like push that
complexity to less sophisticated users
and I have felt that firsthand in
several positions how can we bridge that
Gap apart from selling our users like
watch James talk and then learn some
python I've learned a really good way to
motivate people is to tell them they're
wrong and to criticize them in front of
others
they never bother you again Apparently
after that
another potentially successful way to do
this is to understand that almost all
scientific or analytical users are under
extreme stress to deliver analytical
results in today's market environments
they are under even more stress to
deliver
and if you cannot present these in terms
of what will save them time you're just
another programmer who's chatting in
their ear telling them things like has
anybody ever tried to tell a data
scientist write a unit test and they say
no they're not going to right
we have programmers in the room who tell
their data scientists to write unit
tests and documentation does anybody
here write documentation and that they
tell that they're data science is right
no so the way that I think you do this
is for for every part of python at maybe
about 30 or 40 deep into the language
there is a very clear motivation for why
it exists you can see here we can map
out look you can take the path you want
to take and if you take that path there
will be these consequences if you're
okay with that fine you are a highly
paid professional you know what risk
you're willing to take but there are
other opportunities or other up there
are alternatives that you can try and if
you find that you're willing to
entertain those opportunities there is
material benefit there is a lot in the
Python language that doesn't really have
that much material benefit to analytical
users if you read through the change
logs there's a bunch of stuff that they
add in there where you're just like come
on nobody cares right you know
the statistics module does anybody ever
use the statistics module for anything
real no they use scipy they use numpy
right
the truth of the matter is
if you can tease apart what actually
matters in your life
you can present it to them and you can
have to pick and choose so these are the
four examples that I chose very
particularly because I know in my own
analytical work I have two paths One
path is painful
I want to show you that it doesn't have
to be that way
yes
with that same example of method there
yeah
um how would you you know let's say that
they're aware of that and they but they
don't want to cause a breaking change
later you write a convenience layer that
that stubs out the the intermediary so
you write like Newton slash
I'm gonna say something you're gonna
hate this but um
generally for these kind of closed form
methods also these non-closed four
methods that have some kind of ending
modality generally these are exclusive
bounded modalities you either are one or
the other or the other
and as some of us know there exists a
decomposition of a bounded modality in
other words yeah nobody knows what that
means but anyway
you can take something like that
Newton's method and you can write for
them Newton underscore num steps or
something maybe slightly nicer named and
that just hard codes the I slice
operation or Newton underscore a tall
and you can create that intermediary
lever layer rather that doesn't require
a lot of Maintenance that allows them to
just import something and move on with
their life without compromising the
Integrity of the underlying core code in
fact
raise your hand if you are a user of the
core layer of a specific tool called
matplotlib has anybody here ever
imported matplotlib without the pi plot
one person in the back three people over
here right you provide them with
convenience layers you'll provide them
with the pi plot layer they live in the
the universe they want to live in but
you keep the core layers same for people
who like our colleagues in the back
you know actually want to have that
flexibility
does that satisfy
you're no okay
I need to wrap up fantastic thank you so
much
[Applause]